hi everyone welcome back today i'm really excited
to tell you about one of my favorite topics
in fluid dynamics specifically turbulence and
i've been looking forward to this video for a
long time because it's one of the kind of
most interesting topics in fluids that has
captivated people for really for millennia okay
so um great art has been made to try to capture
the nature of turbulence not just da vinci
we have van gogh and we have the great wave
turbulence is a part of our literature it's a part
of our very language some of my favorite words
uh roiling churning uh turbulent these
mean so much to us and so today what
we're going to talk about specifically is what
is turbulence okay and so you know even though
we have a very intuitive feeling of what
in turbulent flow is uh and is not it's
actually very hard to pin down a single kind
of unique definition that we can all agree on
and so instead of trying to do that i'm going to
bring up some kind of key features of turbulence
and walk you through some examples of turbulent
flows how they're useful and how we might analyze
them as engineers so uh turbulent flows
generally are three-dimensional that's one
of the the hallmark features of turbulence and in
principle you can technically have approximately
2d flows that exhibit turbulence but that's like a
special case so for example weather on the surface
of earth we have a thin atmosphere and so the
fluid dynamics are approximately two-dimensional
but you get weird things like small vorticity
adds up to make bigger and bigger vortices and
form hurricanes which you don't see in kind
of a classical three-dimensional turbulence
so when i say turbulence i really mean kind of
the three-dimensional turbulence where things are
spinning and roiling in three dimensions turbulent
flows are multi-scale okay so they're multi-scale
in space and time which means that there are
big eddies and medium eddies and small eddies
and smaller ones that infinite okay and you'll
notice that all of these features that i'm going
to list are actually in this davinci painting
so this is clearly kind of his attempt at
three-dimensionality it is highly multi-scale
you can see kind of self-similar patterns
it's unsteady even though this is a fixed image
it clearly evokes motion okay so turbulent flows
are not fixed they're not stationary they are
evolving in time they are unsteady and they also
induce mixing in the flow so you can kind of
imagine if you dropped some red food coloring into
this turbulent flow it would very very rapidly
start mixing and diffusing and kind of turn pink
and then dissipate away so these are four of the
canonical features of turbulence that we're going
to investigate more and i'm going to have a few
videos in this series about what is turbulence
and some examples of canonical flows how we can
analyze them things like that i'll even do some
kind of by hand sketches and analysis in a few
of these but this is kind of the big idea we're
going to explore turbulent fluid dynamics which
is literally all around us okay and i'll point out
at the outset this has a tremendous amount
of value for us as engineers when we design
aircraft and ships and jet engines more
fuel-efficient cars and trucks and trains
absolutely you know tremendous applications
for turbulent fluid dynamics in engineering
but i really do think that our fascination with
turbulence goes far beyond just its usefulness and
you know is often motivated by its beauty and by
the fact that it's all around us good okay so when
i was preparing this material i went back to a
lot of the course notes where i learned turbulence
and i was fortunate to learn turbulence from
lex smiths at princeton and you can download
these course notes for mae 553 viscous flows and
turbulence by by lex i highly recommend it this is
absolute gold and a lot of what i'm going to pull
from uh in these videos was you know out of this
this book so i highly encourage you to check this
out because this really is a unique perspective
from one of the absolute foremost leaders in the
field okay good so we're going to start talking
about about turbulence and i want to just start
off with some some videos and some pictures just
to kind of you know get you thinking about whatwe're talking about.
This is one of myfavorite videos by colleagues at KTH in Sweden
and so this is going to be a simulation of aboundary layer
and some of you have seenthis in my videos before
but this is a very veryhigh fidelity numerical simulation
of a developingboundary layer flow... so basically think of the flowover a wing as that wing is going through the air
that's what this is trying to simulate... or maybethe flow over the top of your car or train
andwhat you see here this has all of the features:it's three-dimensional; it's unsteady, it'sevolving in time
Highly multi-scale: look at the vast vast range of scales that are captured bythis turbulent flow
and clearly it's mixing... ifyou started out as a little upstream particleyou'd be bouncing around between these eddies
and after long enough you wouldn't knowwhich way you end up
So this is a greatkind of visualization of a turbulent flow that wecan have in our mind for the kinds of things wemight care about
and simulating and understandingand modeling these flows is very important.
If i'm designing an aircraft, or i'm designinga wing for an aircraft, I need to know what thedrag coefficient is for thatwing
i need to know what the skin frictionas i go through the air or through the water isgoing to be
and i need to be able to know howthat changes as I increase the speed of the flow, decrease the speed of the flow
if I change thecurvature of the airfoil... things like that. Soit's very very hard to model these things.
This is currently an open challenge in engineering,finding better ways of modeling, optimizing, andcontrolling these turbulent flows
so another
cool example and again i kind of got this this
idea from from lex smith's you know when you see
a turbulent flow you'll know it because it's going
to have this multi-scale structure that the more
you zoom in the more you see any piece you zoom
into you're going to see more turbulent structure
and more kind of fine details and resolution
another cool example is this this volcano erupting
you pick any spot and you zoom in and you're going
to see more roiling and churning and turbulence
and actually one of the things i remember
lex saying was you can kind of tell how high
budget a hollywood movie is based on how
many scales are in their turbulent explosions okay
so and you know now i can't watch any action movie
without looking for that multi-scale structure
and i bet you're not going to be able to either
okay another example i really like this ocean
next project you can google and download
data and kind of follow what they're doing
but you know climate the earth's climate
the ocean currents and the atmospheric
patterns are highly turbulent they mix and
kind of transport material across the globe
and this is hugely hugely important for us
to better understand mixing and transport and
dynamics in those turbulent systems as well good
now i also want to give an example one of my
favorite examples is this rayleigh bernard
convection flow where you have a hot plate on
the bottom and a cold plate on the top and you
can see that just from this thermal instability
you get this kind of rising of the warm air and
dropping of the cool air and eventually you're
going to see this start to mix in a pretty chaotic
fashion now this is not three-dimensional so
but it is unsteady multi-scale and and mixing
and this is one of the original problems that
motivated chaos theory so uh lorenz in 1963
was studying this kind of rayleigh bernard
convection flow trying to model the chaotic
churning and overturning of these large large
eddies in this domain and so i think there's
always a very deep connection between turbulent
fluids and chaotic dynamical systems and that's
kind of where this mixing idea comes from i
started with this red blob that was coherent
after a very short amount of time in this
chaotic system it's going to mix and spread
around and that's what happens to particles
in turbulent fluids as well okay and i'll
talk a lot more about chaos in future in future
videos so now i want to get a little bit more
into the mathematics of kind of where this
comes from and how do we analyze these flows
and so we're going to start with the
incompressible navy or stokes equations
and i'll point out that this bold u that i'm
dealing with here is really a three component
velocity field so u v and w are the x the y
and the z or z component of the velocity field
and that's defined everywhere in space and in time
okay so u is a is a vector field and these are the
governing navier-stokes equations now from these
equations you get a whole range of interesting
flow phenomena just by speeding up or slowing
down the flow so we have slow flows up here and
fast flows down here and you get this rich range
of dynamics as you increase the flow velocity
i took this from the the feynman lectures and
it turns out that this this range of complexity
is controlled by this number here called the
reynolds number so 1 over the reynolds number
and the reynolds number is essentially a product
of the fluid density the velocity of the flow the
diameter of the of the sphere in this case
or the cylinder divided by this uh dynamic
viscosity quantity and so you you multiply and
divide all of this up and this one number tells
you if you're going to have a simple flow or
a very very complex flow okay so increasing
either the diameter d or the flow velocity will
make the flow more turbulent okay and decreasing
those makes it more laminar or less turbulent
and this turns out to be an extremely useful
concept that increasing the reynolds number
generally corresponds to an increase in complexity
and turbulence and multi-scaleness of the flow
and in fact the reynolds number can somehow be
thought of as the ratio of the biggest
scales in the flow to the teeny tiniest
scales in the flow so if i have a reynolds number
of a million i'm going to expect eddie's uh you
know that are a million times bigger than the
teeny tiniest eddies or or swirls or vortices
in the flow okay that's just a kind of a rule
of thumb but a very very useful one okay good
you can also plot the drag coefficient versus
this increasing reynolds number so this is a curve
i believe from nasa and you can see that as
the flow field changes as you get this kind
of increased complexity from the turbulence in
this flow field as you increase the reynolds
number or the flow velocity you can see that
you get a wide wide range of drag forces
on that cylinder so you get you know huge range
of drag forces just by changing the flow velocity
now i can't help myself i have to relate this
back to the galileo's famous ball drop experiment
from the leaning tower of pisa you can now
picture dropping this ball from this tower
as it accelerates uh from gravity and speeds
up it's going to transition through all of
these different flow regimes and experience
massively different drag forces at every
stage of its fall and so technically its
acceleration is not going to be you know
exactly a constant due to gravity because it's
going to have this very unsteady uh drag force
due to these turbulent forces and it turns out you
know this is actually pretty consistent with the
older aristotelian view of uh you know a ball's
trajectory is going to depend on its mass or its
density or its ability to resist these unsteady
turbulent forces so just kind of an interesting
connection if you think about that ball drop
experiment it's actually not so obvious that
gravity would be a constant if you did it you know
naively now if you drop a heavy enough ball like a
bowling ball maybe these are kind of negligible
forces okay good uh so i want to go back why do
we call this the reynolds number um so that
number that reynolds number that controlled
the turbulence from laminar or smooth
solutions laminar kind of means layered
and so that means not roiling not unsteady
or turbulent and it turns out that reynolds
osborne reynolds in 1883 was doing experiments
in a pipe so pipe flow is one of the most
important and oldest engineering applications of
fluids is literally just pumping water through
pipes makes sense you you know how big of a motor
do i need to pump all of that water through all
of my city streets okay and to pump all of the
sewage out and so pumping water through pipes has
always been important and osborne reynolds was
studying you know the flow through these pipes
and made a very interesting observation that as
he increased the flow velocity he had these very
different regions or or characteristics of flow
from laminar flow again layered or very kind of
steady flow all the way down to these turbulent
flow scenarios where the flow is kind of roiling
you know what you picture as turbulence now i
don't think this picture does does this experiment
justice because in this picture he looks very
calm and composed but you can imagine if you
were trying to do an experiment of pipe flow
and you were trying to get a smooth solution
to collect whatever numbers you cared about and
it was getting turbulent and roiling you might
have thought that something was wrong with the
experiment that you weren't doing it carefully
enough or that maybe your flow wasn't well
conditioned going in so i think in this picture
he really should have been biting his nails and
pulling his hair out but you know this is a little
bit more composed and actually uh you can go and
see this uh original apparatus at the university
of manchester so it's still there and it's still
kind of on display which i think is kind of cool
but so a long time ago we've known that there
were these transitions as you increase the flow
velocity you can trip the flow into these
very complex disordered turbulent solutions
okay good so let's go back to uh kind of this
picture here so as we increase the reynolds
number we get more and more complex turbulent
flows but what i want to point out here is that
uh this this flow here in the middle this kind of
reynolds number 100 flow is laminar so it's not
turbulent it is unsteady but it's very predictable
so it does the same thing over and over and over
again it's not kind of statistically unreliable
like these turbulent flows in the bottom but the
the middle and the next one are actually very
similar okay so this is the laminar flow and
this is a turbulent flow but they have a
lot of the same patterns and structures
and so what i want to point out is that turbulence
is not random a lot of people think that chaotic
systems or turbulent systems are random and it's
true that they have an element of randomness or
stochasticity to them but they are not random
and so in fact there are what are known as
coherent structures or patterns that emerge even
in these very very complex turbulent flow fields
so this is a picture i pulled from a review
paper by sam tyra and collaborators in 2017 i
absolutely love this figure it shows the flow over
richiri island in japan it's literally you know
the flow over an island this is an atmospheric
flow and then the very very simple laminar low
reynolds number flow past a cylinder in the
bottom and you can see that even though the
reynolds number you know this one's probably
in the millions or tens or hundreds of millions
you get the same qualitative patterns emerging in
these flows okay and so that's really important
is trying to understand and characterize
those big patterns in turbulent flows
now i recently saw this video on on twitter
and i absolutely love it so this is a live
video of the atmospheric flow over guadalupe
island and again clear as day you can see the
emergence of this carmen vortex street forming in
this flow even though it's you know astronomically
high reynolds number extreme complexity but
these patterns these coherent structures emerge
now this was observed early on uh by brown
and roshko in 1974 when they were looking
at these mixing layers so these are compressible
mixing layers in the laminar low reynolds number
and turbulent high reynolds number regime
and you can see that you know even though
the turbulent flow has a lot more complexity and
kind of multi-scale behavior there are a lot of
similarities between the laminar and the turbulent
case given by these coherent structures so brown
was actually the other person i learned fluids
from at princeton gary brown really fantastic
lectures uh rosh go this is not the roscoe of
um chicken and waffles although this roscoe
also was in l.a i love this picture i mean this
really this changed the way that everybody thought
about fluids when this picture came out it's
one of the most famous pictures in all of fluid
mechanics because it showed that even though you
have you know this incredible complexity it has
a lot of the same patterns of much much simpler
flows and that really got people thinking about
these coherent structures how to characterize
them how to quantify them how to model them and so
decades of work maybe the next you know 50 years
up until now a lot of it's been motivated by kind
of this seminal picture very cool okay good so
coherent structures exist uh we want to model
them and characterize them and understand them uh
just a couple of other things i want to point out
there's also something called intermittency i
pulled this again directly from lex smith's book
and intermittency you can kind of picture this if
you have clouds that are kind of developing on the
planes as uh you know as the the ground heats up
and the sun is up and you have this wind and this
boundary layer forming and convecting over earth
some areas of it are going to be more turbulent
than others and some patches you're going to
see are actually pretty still there's going to
be patches of still and turbulent and still and
turbulent and so turbulent flows are often what
is called intermittent and so you can define this
intermittency function which essentially turns on
and turns off and turns on and turns off and it
tells you when it's turbulent or not turbulent
or turbulent or not turbulent either in space or
in time that often happens you can kind of picture
if you have a stick of incense or a cigarette and
the smoke is rising you know sometimes it's going
to be pretty laminar sometimes it's going to be
very turbulent it might actually kind of settle
down again and then get more turbulent again and
this kind of intermittency is a hallmark feature
okay so turbulent flows are everywhere they're
extremely complex they're very important for us
as engineers and scientists and they have all of
these different kind of complexities and features
so how do we get a handle on this complexity
how do we start to model this now what we have
done for you know the last hundred years since
reynolds and probably before is we've tried to
abstract the turbulent fluid dynamics problem
into a few canonical flows simple example flows
that isolate a couple of features you know one or
two features that are that add to the complexity
of turbulence so we can really drill down and
start understanding those constituent pieces now
real engineering flows like you know a boeing jet
flying through turbulence is going to have a lot
of these kind of aspects you know there's going to
be a jet there's going to be a mixing layer and a
boundary layer and isotropic turbulence there's
gonna be all of these different pieces working
together but before we tackle those huge problems
we kind of break it down and distill it into you
know isolated kind of idealized problems there is
a gorgeous book by milton van dyke called an album
of fluid motion where he walks through you know
beautiful flow visualizations of some of these
canonical flows i think you can find pdfs online
it is really really cool you should check this out
but here is just some of my favorite canonical
flows um you know wall-bounded flows like the
boundary layer mixing flows so um you know what
does the flow behind a wing look like uh pipe
flows again pumping you know water or oil through
pipes very economically important and so on and so
forth and so here i'm just going to go through
a couple of these and i'm going to have a whole
lecture the next lecture is going to be all about
zooming into these canonical flows why they're
interesting what are some of the questions we
want to ask and answer okay but this is how we've
approached fluids uh you know essentially for
the last century and this is how we approach most
problems in mathematical engineering where it's
too complex is we try to abstract and boil down
to the simplest piece that kind of exemplifies
our problem now calling these toy problems is a
little bit uh maybe a little too unfair these are
still quite complex and challenging themselves
so just some example wake flows tons and tons of
effort has gone into studying wake flows um if you
want to reduce the drag behind a train or a plane
or a truck or a car you need to understand the
wake behind behind that body also hugely important
for missile design bullets and ballistics
baseballs you know lots and lots of flows create
wakes and those wakes contribute to the drag and
unstudy forces on those bodies another really
important example are mixing layers so again
that brown and rosco example i showed is a mixing
layer many of you have seen these wave makers
where you have kind of oil and water in a
rectangle rotating and it creates these waves
and these mixing layers are really important
canonical flows to understand things like
ocean waves the flow behind a sharp trailing
edge on a wing often creates a mixing layer
and these are very very important another very
important application of fluid dynamics and
another canonical flow is a jet and so there are
supersonic jets you can actually see the acoustic
radiation in this turbulent supersonic jet
uh here you can actually see kind of the mock
lines forming in this jet and jets are extremely
important for you know producing thrust and power
also we want to minimize the noise given
high thrust and high power so you know any
of you who live near lax or heathrow no
i mean there's there's 10 million people
in the top two or three airports alone near the
top two or three airports in the world alone
that are directly impacted by jet noise and
decreasing that jet noise would improve the
quality of life for tens of millions
of people directly okay so huge huge
problem here okay so canonical flows are very
important it's one of the ways that we study
study fluid dynamics we try to break it down
so uh here again are just some of the canonical
flows wakes and jets and mixing layers and
we use those canonical flows to study much
more complex engineering systems like trains and
boats and planes and engines and things like that
okay so many of these flows are going to have
lots of elements of these canonical flows and
i'll talk about that later so for example you know
a wind turbine blade there's going to be boundary
layers and mixing layers and wake flows all of
those interacting in a pretty complex system
and at the end of the day we want to understand
these systems we want to be able to model them
and understand what they will do when we change
different things about our engineering designs
that gives us the ability to optimize for example
design better blades for turbines but also to
control the system to actively manipulate the
behavior of the fluid for better engineering
outcomes to increase lift decrease drag enhance
mixing things like that okay and this is something
i'm very passionate about and one of the reasons i
love turbulence as you know an important field of
fluid mechanics okay good um so i think one of the
last things i want to point out here is again uh
we go back to this we're always going to go back
to the the navy or stokes equations that's kind
of our entry point as a mathematical engineers
and we know that we have this kind of increasing
complexity with the reynolds number so one of
the the kind of important things that you can do
to study these flows and i'm going to
have a whole series of lectures on this
this is going to be the basis of what's
known as turbulence closure modeling
which is one of our approaches for modeling these
systems more efficiently on computers one of the
things you do if we zoom into a turbulent case
is something called the reynolds decomposition so
we're going to take this flow field u which is you
know very complicated function of space and time
and what we're going to do is we're going to break
it apart into an average field u bar and all of
the fluctuating components u prime and so u bar
we get by literally taking this flow u and just
averaging in time we just take flow snapshot think
of a movie of this flow evolving i'm just going to
average all of those frames of the movie in time
and get the average frame that's the mean flow
and then the turbulent fluctuations are just my
original flow minus the mean flow okay and so what
we're doing is we're taking our flow and we're
decomposing it into a function that is the average
flow which is no longer a function of time it's
just a function of space and then all these little
fluctuations all of the turbulent fluctuations
and when i take this flow this decomposition
and plug it into the navier-stokes equations i
get lots of interesting things happening i get
an equation i a navier-stokes equation for the
mean flow and for the fluctuating components and
i can model things more efficiently this way okay
so huge field of reynolds averaging but this is a
very useful perspective where we decompose our
flow into the average flow and the fluctuations
and i'll point out this is a largely historical
why we do this and it's kind of fortuitous is that
historically we didn't have computers to measure
these flow fields accurately in space and time we
didn't have laser technology until the 60s 50s and
60s so that we could build laser sheets to image
the full flow field and experiments and so back
in the olden days you were stuck with single point
measurements hot wires where you would put a hot
wire in the flow and i could maybe measure that
for a long time and figure out what its statistics
were and average and build the fluctuations and
then i could move it one delta x or delta y down
and then i could move it again and move it again
and in the course of a day or a few days i might
be able to measure the entire wake point by point
in a time series fashion but i can't tell what
every point is doing at the same time and so this
idea of averaging your flow is actually you know
goes back to the days when we didn't have enhanced
measurement techniques and computers but it turns
out that it's a very very useful perspective for
modeling today so that's pretty cool okay good
so i'm going to have a whole lecture on reynolds
averaging soon this is going to be kind of a pen
and paper or like lightboard video lecture and i
hope that i have convinced you in this lecture
that turbulence is interesting it's everywhere
it's extremely important and it has these kind of
four canonical attributes that's how these these
are like the fingerprint of turbulence when you
see three-dimensional multi-scale unsteady mixing
flows you know it's turbulence okay stay tuned
there's going to be a lot more to come thank you